До Президентського полку мріють потрапити багато солдатів строкової служби.
Але критерії відбору доволі суворі.
Антон - один із тих, кому пощастило опинитися в лавах елітного полку.
Його призвали на строкову службу навесні 2018.
Місяць тому його обов’язкова півторарічна служба в армії добігла кінця,
але Антон не покинув лав полку.
Мені сподобалося, особливо крокувати і це все.
Воно ж кожному по-різному. Комусь подобається, комусь ні. Мені сподобалося.
Я, наприклад, навчився крокувати. Відбув строкову службу до кінця.
Мені це цікаво стало, вирішив продовжити на контракт.
Тепер юнак несе службу за контрактом.
Каже, вона мало чим відрізняється від строкової,
хіба що живеш вдома і отримуєш за свою роботу гроші.
У майбутньому ж Збройні сили України можуть стати повністю професійними,
а обов’язковий призив на строкову службу скасують.
Такі плани нещодавно озвучив міністр Оборони Андрій Завгороднюк.
Ці зміни він назвав позицією держави і особистою метою.
Втім, поки конкретних механізмів її реалізації немає.
Член парламентського комітету з питань національної безпеки, оборони і розвідки
Давид Арахамія наводить один із варіантів реформи.
Як мені здається, зараз доцільно покроково цей процес зробити.
Наприклад, 20 відсотків призову скоротити спочатку і замістити його контрактною армію.
Потім побачити, чи все нормально, що ми контролюємо процес,
у нас достатньо фінансів, і додати ще 20%.
І от таким покроковим шляхом дійти до 100%.
Ідея відмови від призову - не нова.
У жовтні 2013-го напередодні Революції гідності
Віктор Янукович підписав указ про останній призов і перехід Збройних сил на контрактну основу.
За півроку відбулася анексія Криму і почалася війна на Донбасі.
Саме загроза російської агресії -
основний аргумент противників скасування традиційної строкової служби.
Янукович відмінив обов’язковий призов до армії,
після цього Росія почала збройну агресію проти України.
Я вважаю, що кожен чоловік повинен
пройти службу в армії, тоді після армії він знає, що таке озброєння,
якісь навички там отримає,
а як цього не буде, будуть всі жахатися армії.
А хто ж буде йти захищати Україну?
Армія повинна бути професійною.
Це повинні робити люди, які хочуть, так само, як, наприклад, лікарі.
У них є хист до цього. Вони туди йдуть.
Чому повинні це робити всі? Це що, Радянський Союз чи що?
Частина українців підтримують ініціативу міністра оборони і повний перехід на контрактну армію.
Серед них Данило Гуров.
Він повернувся зі служби в Збройних силах лише місяць тому.
Каже, за півтора року бойову підготовку мав лише в перший місяць.
Чесно кажучи, після навчання у самій частині знань давали нуль.
У нас не було жодних навчань.
Максимум, що нам давали, це раз на місяць у нас були стрільби.
Саме до бойових дій нас абсолютно не готували,
можна сказати, ми були просто робочою силою.
Я не брав такий борг у батьківщини, щоб півтора року так запекло його віддавати.
Поки ідея Андрія Завгороднюка широко обговорюється у суспільстві,
в Україні триває осінній призов.
За три місяці лави Збройних сил та інших формувань
мають поповнити понад 15 тисяч солдатів строкової служби.
Наразі вже набрали понад 8 тисяч військовослужбовців.
Ризики недобору є, хоча, приміром, торік
план осіннього призову до ЗСУ було виконано майже повністю.
Військовий експерт Тарас Чмут стверджує:
без солдатів строкової служби українській армії не обійтися щонайменше найближчі 5-7 років.
Бо військові частини значним чином комплектуються з тих, кого призвали до лав ЗСУ.
З одного боку, ми розуміємо, що у випадку повномасштабної війни
контрактних збройних сил, які ми можемо собі дозволити економічно,
нам ніяк не вистачить для відсічі агресії.
Але, з іншого боку, сама служба має бути не в форматі
півтора чи рік господарських робіт десь у військовій частині, а в форматі
дійсної бойової підготовки з практичними стрільбами,
з якимись тактичними навчаннями в бойових частинах,
які мають бойовий досвід і можуть це передавати.
Говорячи про скасування призову, міністр оборони неодноразово наголошував:
передувати реформі має високий рівень підготовки військових за всіма стандартами НАТО.
При цьому країни-члени Північноатлантичного альянсу
мають різні системи залучення до збройних сил.
У когось армія повністю контрактна, інші - відновлюють обов’язкову службу.
Досвід частини країн НАТО, які бачать російську загрозу,
показують, що строкова служба - це не зовсім те, як було в Радянському Союзі або після того в Україні.
У країнах Балтії після російської агресії щодо України вони відновили призов, якого в них не було.
Він не такий довгий, як у нас, але він направлений на отримання бойової підготовки.
Як показує статистика, в Україні досі десятки тисяч чоловіків у віці 20-27 років
ухиляються від служби в армії.
Тільки в Києві таких нараховується 35 тисяч.
Трапляється, що доходить навіть до фізичного опору, як це сталося днями на Львівщині,
де під час вручення повістки побили представника військомату.
На думку військових і експертів, слова міністра про майбутнє скасування призову
лише утвердять ухильників від служби в їхній позиції.
При цьому кістяк контрактної армії складають, власне, ті,
хто залишається працювати в Збройних силах по завершенні обов’язкових 18 місяців служби.